[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les spectateurs parisiens du Palais des
sports ont la chance d'applaudir un
futur champion du monde des poisplumes é
de 20 ans à peine ce grand champion de
demain c'est le Panaméen Isma Laguna en
culotte blanche
son adversaire le Nigérien rafu King qui
n'est pourtant pas le premier boxeur
venu a été contraint de s'incliner au
point après un combat apr et sévère
launak est encore un boxeur à l'état pur
autrement dit un boxeur qui ignore t les
ficelles du métier utilise toute la
gamme des coup les plus simples mais
avec quelle vitesse et quelle
efficacité rfw King malgré son ardeur ne
peut que s'incliner devant un tel
adversaire et personne en définitive ne
conteste la victoire du jeune panaméen
Laguna avec avec lui la Nouvelle Vague
s'apprête à prendre la relève il était
temps les bisons qui furent pendant des
siècles les rois de la prairie
canadienne ont été vers la fin du siècle
dernier sur le point de disparaître
heureusement le gouvernement canadien a
pris des mesures de protection sévère
qui ont permis de reconstituer un
troupeau de 14000 bisons qui vivent en
liberté dans leur habitat
[Musique]
naturel année à l'automne dans le but de
surveiller la croissance et la santé du
troupeau les équipes forestières avec
leurs hélicoptères se mettent en devoir
de rassembler la masse des bisons et de
diriger leur tribus vers les centres de
préservation de la race où sont réunis
enclos et
laboratoires
en Autriche les recherches commencé
voici bientôt un mois pour retrouver au
fond du lactoplitz le mystérieux trésor
que les nazis y coulèrent à l'heure de
la défaite ont produit un premier
résultat la caméra de télévision
sous-marine a permis de repérer au
milieu de différents débris une caisse
que les hommes grenouilles ont réussi à
dégager comme certains l'avaient
pronostiqué il s'agit de fauses bannotes
britannique que les nazis avaient
fabriqué et dont il se promettaient
d'inonder le monde afin de causer à
l'Angleterre la plus grave des crise
financière voici donc résolu un premier
mystère mais le lactoplitz en recelle
peut-être
d'autres à Saigon le nouveau
gouvernement vietnamien s'est installé
les principales figures en sont le
Président Monsieur Nguyen nocto et le
général Dang van min qui fut
l'organisateur du coup d'État et qui est
l'homme fort du nouveau régime le chef
de la jeinte des généraux pense que la
première tâche du gouvernement est de
regagnner la confiance du pays pour
battre les communistes du vietkong la
population a réservé un accueil
chaleureux au bons libéré ces mesures
jointes à la volonté de ne pas se livrer
à des représailles devraient contribuer
à une rapide stabilisation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
politique à la fois plaignante et
accusée la délégation algérienne
conduite par Monsieur boutflica s'est
rencontré à Addis Abeba avec la
délégation marocaine devant l'assemblée
des états-africains réunie sous la
présidence du Négus AES etacier et de
Monsieur ddoutiam ministre des Affaires
étrangères du Sénégal les 32 états de
l'organisation de l'Union africaine ont
à donné suite aux accords de bamaco et
doivent selon les paroles du ngus mettre
tout en œuvre pour assurer une solution
pacifique au conflit
[Musique]
algémocain à Paris c'est la saison des
prix littéraires qui s'est ouverte chez
drouan où fidèle à une tradition solide
les académiciens goncour s'étaient
réunis pour déjeuner et pour
voter et comme à l'habitude Philippe a
risqué l'étouffement pour annoncer le
résultat le prix concours 19 3 a été
attribué au 6e tour à Armand Lanou pour
son roman quand la mer se retire par
saintvoie Jean-Marie Gustave leclésio
lauréa du prix renaodo a partagé avec
lui cette journée de
[Musique]
gloire il suffit de passer devant un
lycée de Paris pour s'en apercevoir la
mode fait aujourd'hui partie des
préoccupations des moins de 15 ans à
l'âge où leur grandes sœur n'y songeaent
guerre des générations de lycéenes
marquent leur goût de façon déterminée
elles ont leur mode qui parfois même
déteint sur celle des grands cette
saison elle raffole de bonnets tricotés
à pompon par exemple certaines la
sortissent à une veste écossaise le BET
tricoté a lui aussi des fidèles quant au
chaussettes noir elles font fureur la
casquette Sherlock Holmes connaît
toujours un succès marqué comme la
longue écharpe de ton et l'on voit
apparaître les guêtres
[Musique]
longues à 14 ans maintenant on sait ce
qu'on
[Musique]
veut ce qui est arrivé à saintternin est
déjà arrivé ailleurs en Bretagne ce
n'est pas la première fois qu'on voit
les gendarmes enquêté dans la lande et
les habitants de la petite paroisse du
Finistère ne sont pas les seuls à se
poser des
questions cette fois on a volé le Père
Éternel c'est une statue d'un calvaire
du 15e siècle qui a disparu r un
calvaire en plein champ voilà qui n'a
pas facilité l'enquête d'autant qu'ici
les langues sont parfois longues à se
délier vous monsieur bgil qu' av
constaté la
disparition ou il y a longtemps que vous
êtes ça fait 3 mois et demi à peu prèsoi
demi oui mais j'ai tardé un petit peu à
avant de prévenir personne quoi le
calvaire avait donc intéressé de façon
très particulière certains touriste un
connaisseur sans aucun doute alors il
m'a dit comme ceci ben il est beau ce
CALV j'ai dit oui
parce que ça vaut ça vaut beau tout qui
il m'a parlé de 10 millions voà alors
moi je lui ai dit comme ceci ben si ça
vaut 10 millions moi puisque c'est ce
mes droits moi je vais prendre ce
calvaire là je vais la démolir alors
comme ça j'aurais 10 million alors il a
fait un sourire
quoi c'est ainsi qu'on est plus loin de
croire en Bretagne que sur les
innombrables calvaire les précieuses
statues sont devenu depuis un an la
proie d'un véritable gang qui opérerait
pour le compte de collection h si bien
que tous les villages tremblent pour
leur patrimoine artistique qui est comme
chacun sait un des plus riches de France
la seule église de saintnain renferme de
véritables trésors d'art ancien bien
capable de faire rêver des connaisseurs
[Musique]
indélicats va-t-on mettre tout cela sous
clé toutes ne sont pas enfermés comme
dit la presse dans des coffres forts non
il faudrait pas d'ailleurs ces heres
d'art doiv être visible de tout le monde
c'est c'est un trésor pour bien sûr pour
la paroisse mais les paroissiens sont
fiers quand les touristes passent et
viennent voir ses uvres dans
l'Église c'est bien là le drame
aujourd'hui des villages bretons chaque
nuit au bout de chemin désert des
calvaires sont là des statues sans âge
des pièces uniques sont à l'intérieur
d'église dont les portes battent à tout
vent et non pour seule protection que le
respect de chacun il les afend pendant
des siècles mais aujourd'hui apparemment
il n'y suffit
[Musique]
plus dans le Finistère les côtes du nord
le morbillant on a enregistré des
dizaines de disparitions nocturne et
tout récemment on est allé jusqu'à voler
un ménir atterré devant tant d'audace
les vieux Bretons ne veulent plus croire
qu'à l'intervention des esprits
malfaisants certains les les les vieux
bretons viux bretons ceux qui qui ne
parle que le Breton pense que ça ce sont
des méfait du Corgan euh c'est surtout
l'oiseau de la mort qu'on appelle l'
breton le Nanou nou mais qu'est-ce que
c'est exactement le Corgan et le Nanou
le corigan vous savez c'est enfin mon
avis c'est enfin d'près les les don et
les vieux et la traduction même du
dictionnaire ce sont des nains
maléfiques
euh petits et des genes de bouffons si
vous voulez qui hantaient alors la
campagne campagne vantz il serait très
peu vraemblable que ce soit les C les
Corgan qui emmènent même des ménir
puisqu'on a parlé aussi de vol de ménir
et de Domen ou oui vous savez euh je je
ne le pense pas quand même oui il en est
tout de même qu'on ne volera pas de
[Musique]
siôt qui aurait pu imaginer le jour de
1953 où John fideral Kennedy épousait
Jacqueline Lee Bouvier que 10 ans plus
tard cette radieuse image de bonheur
s'effacerait sous une tâche de s que
John Kennedy tomberait sous les balles
d'un assassin candidat du Parti
démocrate porté à la présidence des
États-Unis avec Lindon Johnson pour
vice-président il succédait à la Maison
Blanche à eisenower à l'âge de 43
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ans il inaugurait sa présidence par un
voyage en Europe où sa visite au général
de Gaulle et l'accueil chaleureux de
Paris préluda à la rencontre de rutchov
à Vienne rencontre qui ne provoquait pas
toutefois la détente
[Musique]
escomptée son voyage le conduisait
également à bonne auprès du chancelier
adonoer voyage au cours duquel la
population allemande lui faisait une
sorte de
Trion mais deux crises majeures allaient
secouer l'Amérique et le monde l'affaire
de Cuba d'abord l'installation à 250 km
des côtes américaines de rampe à missile
soviétique allait mettre le monde de pas
de la guerre Kennedy su prendre à
l'égard de Castro et de ses alliés
l'attitude ferme qui éloigna le
danger une autre crise menaçait le drame
de la ségrégation dont la marche des
Noirs réclamant l'égalité des droits
n'était que le signe officiel il e le
sens humain et généreux dans lequel le
problème doit être réglé il meurt
laissant l'exemple d'un homme qui avec
la confiance du monde libre su apaiser
les défiances de l'Est et l'image d'une
vie heureuse au milieu d'une heureuse
laissant aussi un grand destin
[Musique]
inachevé